can you explain to people why in Ice Age
isn't like the movie I
think for humans is when it's an ice age
everything in the world is completely
frozen over nothing can live except a
little squirrel with acorns called The
Ice Age it makes sense well we're in the
Ice Age we're still in it like
we're in an interglacial period in an
ice age right now so if there's a
glacier 53 degrees in New York while
we're filming this yeah yeah
it's not snowball earth like it's not
this planet snowball idea you know you
know millions and millions of years ago
there may have been periods like that
but no I I Ice Age and the with a
glacial maximum refers to like when we
had the laurentai the cordaran and the
European glaciers you know these two
miles of ice that were sitting up on top
of uh the northern hemisphere of the
planet uh it was generally colder but
there were plenty of temperate zones and
even tropical zones
of glacial ice yeah that qualifies a
time period to be an ice age they
generally go on like the extent of the
glaciers and so we can see from you know
glacial till and the moraines and all of
these geological features about how far
the glaciers extended you know we would
have been buried under a couple miles
right here
um back you know in that period but it's
it's you know it's it's also you know
the sea levels were 400 feet lower
because all that water's up on the land
now and all that mount sea levels rise
all that stuff and yeah so that abruptly
ended and so we've known it's kind of
interesting it's it's all work that's
happened in the last couple decades
really that has has really Advanced our
understanding of what occurred at the
end of that last glacial maximum because
it was violent like that's the thing we
don't it it turns out it was
tremendously violent like that again so
we understand this the younger driest is
the ice age or it is the violent time
the younger driest is essentially the
boundary between what we would call the
pleistocene which was the glacial like
the end of the like we would generally
call it the ice age but that's the like
the glacial maximum and the Holocene
which is the era we're in now this nice
warm weather that's been pretty stable
for
you know 10 000 years or so like that's
that's where we live it's the reason
this is the reason why we've got a
civilization gotcha the younger driest
is the transition point between that and
it gets crazy wacky in terms of so
something happened 12 000 years ago yeah
12 800 years ago it's a period between
12 800 years ago and eleven thousand six
hundred years ago and if you go back
it's it's this tumultuous time so we we
kind of have learned this from Ice core
data so we go and drill down and
Antarctica and Greenland and we we drill
down late because right down at the ice
you extract these big tubes of ice
because every year you know the snowfall
gets laid down on there and it's
compacted and you can do analysis on it
and look at things like oxygen Isotopes
and determine temperature and
accumulation of snow and all these
different things about the past a
similar thing almost like with trees and
Rings yes pretty much you're doing that
with ice with ice and you can go back
hundreds of thousands of years so what
we've learned is that something happened
like we're coming out of this more or
less warm gentle we're warming up from
this you know glacial maximum but then
all of a sudden it just guys boom down
to these severe cold for like you know
eight seven eight hundred years and then
it's boom Jack back up again by another
event and then it's it's sort of it's
this gentle warming thing that gets us
up to more or less the temperature we
have now uh but there's this really
violent period in between called the
younger driest it's you go back further
there's ups and downs as well but the
the other thing that correlates to the
younger drivers is this Extinction event
we've known about that forever right
we've dug up Mammoth bones and you know
saber-toothed tigers and American lions
and short-faced bears like all these
giant animals it's not the dinosaurs but
they were animals that exist now animals
well no it's no animals that were here
but only some 12 to 13 000 years ago so
it's the mega fauna Extinction think
about the mammoths like some people get
agafana for the people well megaphone is
like any mammal or large animal with a
body weight I think over like 40
kilograms pounds
um yeah so any that's the yeah 80 pounds
or something 90 pounds something like
that so G and the crazy thing is as many
species of Mega fauna that there are
alive today that's basically how many
went extinct in a very short period of
time also in that younger dress period
like eleven thousand six hundred to
twelve thousand eight so younger driest
is not the event it's the time period
during that's after the event before
things start to normalize yeah so it's
this period of time where it's this
tumultuous time we've got these crazy
swings in temperatures we've got these
massive sea level in like these water
pulses with it the sea level rise is
tremendously very violently and we've
got an Extinction event now all tied
into this one period from Ice core
samples and now since 2007 there's more
than 160 papers that have also shown
there was a cosmic impact at that time
so digging in that layer so in that same
layer in the dirt you dig down the
strata layers you can all that stuff
wear those megaphone Mega fauna bones
are a lot of the extinction bones at
that same layer that's where we find
what you call impact proxy so shock
sensor shock synthesized Nano diamonds
so it's basically the impact and it's
the it's the byproducts of extreme heat
and pressure
and like soot layers and carbon and like
all these different indicators of
basically Cosmic impacts like these
gigantic explosions so this is where the
Carolina Bays thing is well the Carolina
Bays may or may not it it seems like it
ties into this event but no let's not go
there then yeah that's it's like a fall
it's almost like Splash damage it's
Carolina Bays it's just a byproduct
almost of of a big Cosmic impact this is
like the same this is like just
unimaginably violent events these Cosmic
either it's Air Bursts or it's huge
impacts of stuff that's like a mile two
mile wide coming in at you know 40 000
kilometers a second kind of thing and
and just pounding into the Earth and
then it creates these these uh these
tellers these microscopic Telltale uh
signatures like uh magnetic carbon
spherols shock sensor size Nano diamonds
there's a whole list of them there's all
these signs a lot of these scientific
papers that have now figured that out
evidence of impact it's they call it
impact proxies yeah so it's the thing we
don't quite have are craters now that
stuff that Randall is working on but you
you will also imagine some of these
impacts they might not have all been
impacts they might have been Air Bursts
there was a good there was an air burst
so it's where it blows up before it hits
the ground so what we see now with like
uh what is it a shooting stars and stuff
like that yeah there was a big one in
tunguska um in Siberia yeah that's the
Russian one yeah the Russian one isn't
that impact though no it was really
adverse they it was an air burst but I
mean a giant area there's only a tiny
little rock compared to what we would so
if flattened an area despite it being an
air burst oh yeah I think if think of
like a big bomb going off it's just a
shock wave comes down and just goes oh
maybe you can even get a picture up of
that to show it because it still hasn't
even recovered yeah in Siberia right
well there's pictures of all these just
trees locked down by matchsticks but you
know like acres and Acres over here so
so some people go well where are the
creators if there's this massive impact
and what you're saying is you don't need
a crater in order for the impact to have
extreme damage I well that's right so
you'd still you might have some remnant
it could have been an air burst a lot of
people mistake
um the research the latest research
really shows it was a series of impacts
it was a or air burst it wasn't just
like one big one there was a whole range
of them yep it's like an asteroid belt
almost it's actually it was actually a
disintegrating comment this is a funny
thing so it's it's a common enki now
this came into our solar system a long
time ago it's been broken up there's
actually a it's formed what's a meteor
stream that runs around the Sun and
Loops out and we cross through it twice
a year it's the it's the torrid meteor
stream I think it's like
June and October so we sort of cross in
over it twice right I think Graham
talked about it in his series he does
and it's like we don't know if there's
large chunks still in this like we do
run into this same period and it's
there's a lot related to that time
period in October the Chicago fires uh
of our figures like 18 or 19 something
the the uh the the the Great Chicago the
Great Chicago Fire started by a comet it
may have been an air burst and or it
might have been a Remnant or even a gas
bubble that came in from something
because it also on the same day you had
the pastigo uh forest fire which was
like
um I think in in southern Canada or
somewhere like that is one of the
craziest stories you'll ever hear
because this huge area in the same time
frame this massive fire spread like like
it's unimaginable conflagration as well
as what happened in Chicago all in that
same time period the same time period
when tunguska hit that same time of year
when we're crossing this medial stream
so it's like you know this is not always
the you know these little shooting stars
aren't always the friendliest of things
I think a lot of that ties back to to uh
to to this meteor stream and potentially
this um yeah this this blew my mind a
little bit when I was watching Graham's
piece because I think my perception is
probably similar to most people which is
like there's been a couple comments that
hit the earth like one or two every 65
million years and then it's done and
then Mark showed me this picture of all
the comments that have hit the Earth
right he just sends me the picture he
goes hey look at this and then I look
and I go wow that's a lot of comments
and then on the bottom of the picture
goes since 1994. yeah yeah I thought
this was all that ever hit it so and I
think it was I don't know if it was you
but I know Rogan was messaging me about
this too yeah
2013. what 19 years that's crazy so so
and then Rogan said this as well to me
he's like yeah we're in a shooting
gallery and Cosmic shooting out and it's
better we don't think about things like
this by the way it's better we assume
it's just a big one hits and then like
okay that's why there's that little hole
near Cancun and then the dinosaurs go
away and then we're back to normal yeah
it's better for the average person
because I don't recycle as it is now but
if you told me it's possible that next
year we're gonna get hit by some big
I'm not recycling ever I'm not
gonna do a single good thing for the
environment yeah I was thinking that
like I I dude these political arguments
we have like how many genders are there
have a million who gives a yeah
yeah so we're gonna die
yeah okay okay so this this is happening
between 12 and uh yeah 11 000 six eleven
thousand years ago so that's that's the
younger draws period right so and that's
that is the cat that's the true key to
me that unlocks the story of
civilization because if that event
happened today to us our civilization is
gone if we survive it we will be knocked
back to hunter-gatherers and in a
generation or two we'll be sitting
around the campfire
telling ghost stories about plasma TVs
and dancing around with black shiny
rocks trying to turn it on and say well
this thing will give you answer to
anything and we can talk to someone the
other you know it's magic can you paint
that picture a little bit like if Young
address happens today yeah what happens
geopolitically like it does away from
the entire world it depends where it
lands what happens I mean if you're
anywhere near the actual impact site or
the areas I mean you're just gone every
every building oh done I mean if you're
sitting around here it's just
instantly disintegrated the entire
planet not well if it's big enough I
mean that's the problem is that you go
back far enough in these these
Extinction events I mean some of them
have eliminated like 99.9 of Earth of
life on the planet if that happens it's
game over like we're back to microbes
and let's start again but it's
you know
um so we're back to rats it's whatever
whatever the hell crawls out of the
Ponder next time and give it a billion
years and see where we end up but it's
no if if something mediums or relatively
small the younger driest I mean that's
an Extinction event right it knocked
humans around knocked off half of the
big animals on the planet at the time
all of the woolly mammoths I mean
there's there's literally anything near
that event we see this in some of the
bones of these Mammoth graves right it's
absolutely crazy think about an
elephant's femur how much force it takes
to break the femur of an elephant
there's there's literally these
elephants had their feet in mud and
their their leg bones are just snapped
clean off and there's hip bones up near
their heads and they're just jumbled up
there's whole cat this whole caves I get
what you're saying you're basically
looking at the skeleton and you've never
seen an elephant skeleton being
absolutely destroyed like this and there
isn't an animal big enough that's alive
that's going to do it it's not like
there's some King Kong that's running
around snapping elephant legs right yeah
oh yeah it has to be they're either
falling off a cliff well their feet are
in the ground like there's literally
they're stuck so their feet are still in
this mud and then the bones are snapped
off and they're all jumbled I mean
there's oh so so they're standing there
and then they just got stuff like this
this yeah this shock wife hits him yeah
in other places there's all these Mega
faunas mixed up bears and and tigers and
cats and trees and just this like Forest
just all smashed up and jumbled together
they found like that like a landslide
but it's but it's much more violent like
it's essentially I think what's what
you're looking at is these these things
were hit by a shock wave yeah as a
result of this now painting the picture
if it if it hits anywhere near an ocean
or if it lands in an ocean tsunami
tsunamis like they so you have these you
know giant tsunamis moving at the speed
of sound that might be half a mile high
or whatever it's just gonna just water
destroys everything uh knocks out all
the cities you probably have I mean
forget electricity and grids and stuff I
actually think this is why that some
governments around the world are making
these giant underground bases which may
have also been what happened in the past
because in Turkey right
well Darren kuyu yeah but also Egypt
there's evidence for this all over the
world and you know there's all sorts of
strange Colorado the airport yeah
Colorado the airport the Cheyenne
Mountain up there in uh Colorado just
like where NORAD is and everything
there's giant underground bunkers you
can go that sort of tick tock of a guy
driving a big ass truck and you can just
like huge this isn't even conspiracy
this is known right like it's like a
doomsday bunker I don't know if you say
doomsday but yeah it's an underground
bunker that's as big as or twice as big
as the airport yeah and they can hold
like 4 000 people or something like that
this is the end of civilization the
government's thinking about it I saw an
RF I know a guy who knows a guy who who
is involved in some governments up they
they put out an RFP what does that mean
like a request for proposal for tech
companies to go we need a drone system
you know Prometheus movie yep where they
throw it up in the air and runs off and
Maps these underground but they wanted
that type of system that can work
without GPS because they're interested
in fighting Wars in underground cities
because they think that they think what
happened where it might go in the future
so they're trying
if there's an extinction level event
there's going to be violence followed
very quickly yeah yeah you would love a
series about this yeah
um yeah it depends where you're on the
planet and if you how your lock holds
wherever you are I mean what were you
saying about the turkey thing or Darren
kuyu yeah well so there's there's
evidence for underground cities ancient
underground cities as well yeah all over
yeah I think so I definitely places like
Cappadocia and during turkey they could
have held hundreds of thousands of
people have you seen have you seen any
of these no no this is incredible yeah
they're basically carve cities out yeah
underground with access to air yep and
water there's underground Rivers so they
knew where the river was and the water
line was so you have everything you need
but and that speaks to being very
Advanced
underground city and we know where the
water is you know how to access the
water and how many people can they hold
well Darren kill you I'm pretty sure was
was the figures I think yeah that's only
a tiny part of it I think it could have
been 100 I've heard up to like hundreds
of thousands of people certainly more
than 50
000 people and but you same thing in
Egypt and there's rumors of this stuff
all over the place I mean there's giant
underground networks of tunnels
underneath Sakara I think underneath
Giza all over Egypt now is it possible
that they're using this during the time
where there's tons of comet impact I
think that's probably why I mean it
speaks to someone who they may have
known it was coming like you've got
these Indica like if the Sphinx is
marking the age of Leo and you've got
these alignments I mean they're pointing
at that for a reason because that time
period is also that of cataclysm right
it's at least in the last processional
cycle the last 26 000 year period it
kind of lines up to it and Gobekli Tepe
there's a lot of research done into that
side as well it may be an astronomical
calendar yeah and a historical one but
it seems to point at this time it's like
it's like they're transmitting a message
down through time this is it's possible
that's telling us look at this time like
this time means something this was bad
like figure it out and if they knew it
was coming maybe they were preparing
these things as you know the doomsday
bunkers and place you could survive
until it was the outside was nice enough
to come back out and go holy what's
the uh what's the uh stone that has the
different constellations on it and go
back Lee tappy uh Graham talked about it
yeah it's like pillar 13 or pillow
pillow seven or closure five or whatever
yeah but basically has this like and
maybe he might be Taking Liberties on it
but like they have an organization of
the constellations that happens to the
last time the constellations were
organized in that manner there was a
global cataclysm right right so it's
like they're not usually organized like
that but when they are this is when it
was it was basically go time yeah yeah
you know and it lines up with the
younger dress and it's uh okay and where
do they think younger dries did hit and
what do they think the damage was so I I
think I it was a northern hemisphere uh
impact I think I think you're mostly
looking at ice impacts onto the what was
the laurentide and Calderon ice sheets
covered most of like North America and
Canada I actually think that some of the
Great Lakes Randall's doing a lot of
really good Research into what could be
actual impact formations in the geology
of the northern United States and in
Canada today because the other thing is
we know that that's where this this a
lot of the the Melt water from these
glaciers came out right this is the
evidence for you guys haven't been up to
the scablands Eastern Washington State
no no I've seen the videos it's crazy
amazing these these giant coolies you're
talking one of these coolies just one of
several of them what's a a
is like a canyon but with no water yeah
it's just like this giant like thousand
think of like the Grand Canyon but you
know much super wide thousand foot
horror 800 foot so a racist term for
Indians in South Africa so I got it I
got a little bit uncomfortable
but uh continue sorry it's with a u in
it okay all right okay
but it's uh yeah it's the channeled
scablands and it's it's basically the
outwash of this water there's tremendous
floods we know now that you know this
this all happened at the end of the Ice
Age but it completely destroyed that
environment carved up it ripped through
this land it I mean you're talking about
a single one of these of these channels
and there were multiple of them it's you
know like 50 100 times the volume of all
the rivers on the earth at once oh wow
just like almost like a billion cubic
feet per minute at where it all gathered
up it's just the the catastrophic flood
in this let's just tour through it like
the flood that's the way it's carved
that channel the actual water was
probably three four hundred feet above
that and it just it just ripped through
here all the national parks in the
United States of America are just
remnants from the latest cataclysm
America yes America cataclysm has made
some cool they do like this is
stunning and if you go down to uh where
was I in like Southern Utah and stuff
like that you see these like even
they're not cataclysms exactly like the
damage from the water damage from
Canyons create some like stunning ones
why can't it just be like gentle erosion
over millions well that was the argument
for a long time until until you had guys
like jayhaw and bretts was a
catastrophist he's and then Randall
Carlson's doing a lot of good work in
this space and now this at least up here
in the channel scablands they have swung
around so it's a long story it's it
comes back to religion funnily enough
because the story of religion was always
catastrophism right what's the story in
the Bible it's Noah's flood it's the
great flood right so that was always
where we got our answers from so you
have the Age of Enlightenment the Age of
Reason starts science has its Beginnings
geology emerges as a as a as a fledgling
science and for something like 60 70
years a stated goal of geology was to
get as far away from the catastrophism
of religion as they could so think of it
as like a massive over correction they
said they went out there and said you go
out and you have to explain every
feature we see on the landscape with
gradualism or uniformitarianism which is
the gentle slow erosive processes that
we see in place today like the you know
streams slowly eroding stuff Hills and
shapes taking form so that's what ends
up in all the textbooks and some stuff
is still explained like that and it's
it's frankly nonsense so but now we're
sort of coming back in the other
direction going you know what some of
these Landscapes and features are the
result of catastrophic flooding and at
least up here in in Washington state
they're like yes there's still arguments
going on some people think it's like 50
60 floods Randall thinks it was one or
two I think Randall's right uh he says
he has significant evidence for it
there's all sorts of problems with like
how ice dams reform it's kind of a
convoluted long story but this does
align this model this environment aligns
with like the Melt water pulses so
everything wraps up and shows that in
that period that younger dries period
when all we had all this ice on land
that all ended up in the ocean in a big
bloody hurry it's like you and it just
that's we and we don't
you know you need an external source of
energy for that if you took that lump of
ice that was on top of North America and
you plopped it down and the warmest
Waters at the time say somewhere around
Indonesia it'd take 30 000 years yeah it
would still be here but it melted in an
incredibly short period of time so you
need this source of energy turns out
then you combine that with all of the
strata work this so it's like the macro
scale and the micro scale the macro
scale we've got these catastrophic
Landscapes of work around or Carlson the
micro scale we've got all the work of
the Comet research group 160 plus
peer-reviewed papers looking at the
science so we've narrowed in we're like
God damn this was a violent period it
probably knocked our species Graham says
we're a species with amnesia for this
very reason it's a great analogy so you
turn all of this around I think that's
why catastrophism the younger driest is
the key that unlocks this longer story
of civilization in human history because
now you've got all this other evidence
these stories that are embedded in
religions and origin stories and
cultures that speak of earlier times
every
every culture out there is like hey our
ancestors went through either flood or
fire it knocked them down they had to
rebuild it's like is this all
yeah there's a flood myth and Mayan uh
mythology there's a flood myth and like
Christian there's I'm sure there's
Indian I mean everyone yeah but and this
makes sense if these comments were
hitting more regularly and then you were
experiencing these floods I do I I think
some of these towers include basic
eyewitness accounts of these floods if
you go to the other vectors directory on
there you can pull up a few the
Mahabharata literally talks about swarms
of meteors coming out of the sky
Revelation 8 9 what's the Mahabharata
it's mahabara
Hindu story oh okay Hindu epic yeah yeah
you go to other vectors in there oh in
this one yeah
as third one down yep now I guess my
question is if there's a gap between
hinduism's 4 000 years old the younger
driest period is as many as what 12 000
BC so yeah yeah no no thousand years old
12 000 BC no just twelve thousand years
12 000 years ago so this is an 8 000
year Gap how does that story hold up for
8 000 years if theoretically we went
back to and I'm not saying this is
picking you I'm just curious no and I'm
sure you've thought this through uh if
we went theoretically back to a stone
age how did we maintain these these
eyewitness accounts for eight thousand
well I think that's they get deified and
they get put into stories that's how we
that's like the oral tradition that's
how we transmit the data down through
time not only I think other eyewitness
accounts and stuff like this I mean
Revelation 8 Mahabharata uh all of these
stories that I think it's an oral
tradition and and there's also evidence
in all of these stories for Celestial
knowledge for those that same
processional numerology I talked about
there's there's a whole book called
Hamlet's Mill that's a complicated book
but they've essentially showed in that
that from all these cultures all around
the world there seems to be that same
processional numerology these 72s the
stuff that correlates to the cycles of
the heavens and the cosmic world is also
encoded in these tales in some cases
in civilizations where we know they had
no clue about this it all of it points
to like these
like a common ancestor a common uh
progenator of this story yeah I think
that I mean like to be fair some of
these things uh the biblical flood the
flood of Moses for example might have
been related to an event that happened
called Berkle crater which was about
five thousand um I think it was 5000 BC
or 5000 years ago uh they may be smaller
events that have generated flows like
this isn't the only impact like birkel
crater was a the hotter meaning it would
have flooded the Middle East right
around the right sort of time it landed
in the Indian Ocean
800 foot tsunamis hit Madagascar and and
the coast of Western Australia yeah are
both India too yeah I would have
washed up north yeah yeah yeah so I
think that a lot of the stuff gets
transmitted down through time with oral
traditions and it gets put into these
stories and characters and deified
because that's how we we retain that
data and transmit it down through time
and what was the timeline of the
pyramids the Great Pyramids and the
younger dryas well I mean they're not if
you ask the Orthodox egyptologists
they're not related like the youngster
younger dryers twelve thousand eight
hundred years old to like 11 600 uh
pyramids started about 4 500 years old
according to the mainstream story so you
know 2500 BC but it's possible that
those pyramids could have been made 30
000 years ago it could be or at least
the structure the base of them that's a
form of them that was there like I said
you you can't really
is very difficult to distinguish what
the dynastic Egyptians did to it they
probably worked on them repaired them
maybe have done some of the work we just
don't know that's that's part of the
challenge of looking at this stuff